I think this uh uh space cadet camp and
having Cracker Barrel be part of it oh
my God I didn't see that yeah really
yeah oh that I totally missed that
yeah your Cracker Barrel is going to be
uh offering home style brunch bites oh
my God I know right I mean if only they
could bring if only they could bring in
that Waffle House
I mean I've been to that Waffle House so
many times if only they could figure out
a way to get the Waffle House truck in
there
um on one end of Camp you've got
Cracker Barrel on the other end you've
got Waffle House that would be perfect I
know oh my God they do they do have a
food truck Waffle House does so they do
happen yeah I know they haven't I okay I
thought you meant they have it at
Bonnaroo I haven't I've never seen it I
want to bring the food truck bring the
food truck Waffle House people isn't
that fun though I mean yeah that's
clever yeah that's clever people coming
out of town and get a sausage and
biscuit or a biscuit and gravy or
whatever a little bit from the south so
anyway you know we can uh
we can get in when is the last time you
went to a Cracker Barrel it's got to be
15 years for me probably saying yeah
everything uh because you know you know
me I'm not out at 2 A.M in the morning
that's the only time you're not out at 2
p.m in the afternoon you don't leave
that house and I'm not going to a
Cracker Barrel at 2 p.m
Taco you see I bet I bet I bet of all of
us you're the last one to go to a
Cracker Barrel aren't you you've been to
a Cracker Barrel recently yeah I love
Cracker Barrel I'm two miles from a
Cracker Barrel here
uh-huh actually I take it back I have
been within the last five years this
Sunday uh you know what I can tell you
exactly when it was it was a trip to
Memphis for High School girls soccer we
used to always stop in the Cracker
Barrel at Jack in Jackson Tennessee
yeah did it for four straight years so I
think I think I can Mark I think I can
mark the last time I've been to a
Cracker Barrel the last time I went to
church because it just went hand in hand
with after church went to crack a barrel
uh true that's true yeah forgive me for
I have sinned